là haut entre ciel et terre un chemin de
pierre conduit au pays des chouettes des
serpents et des loups le hall où jean
l'endroit le plus désert d'europe
occidentale ici pendant l'été trente
personnes par semaine viennent en stage
d'assureurs on boit l'eau du torrent
bien sûr ni téléphone ni électricité le
téléphone on a demandé s'ils pouvaient
nous mettre le téléphone nous ont dit
non vous rêvez vous êtes au bout du
monde
en guise de vacances six jours dans la
nature en survie douce dans les sacs à
dos le minimum nécessaire pour dormir et
surtout rien à manger
au menu juste les plantes qu'on aura
tous charcuterie pas le enfin patricia
on espère que personne a mis à saucisson
et une bouteille de rouge comme son sac
à dos les chénopode l'amarante l'origan
et l'ortie lortie qui compte sept fois
plus de vitamine c que l'orangé ou
encore trois fois plus de fer que les
épinards savez l'histoire des épinards
et c'est plein de faire les épinards
sortie saint finement mais dit
servez vous oui servez-vous tout le
monde à table peu attention à pas
marcher dessus les uns un diction de m
les clients donnent à la soupe d'orties
mijote dans le four à énergie solaire
dégustation après la soupe d'orties la
galette de l'est du sauvage et non
découvre au programme l'apprentissage du
feu il faut chauffer le voit par
frottement jusqu'à 400 degrés on obtient
de braise fragile qui vont animer la
paille sous les regards attentifs faire
le feu assez magique a qu'à voir le
regard des gens lorsque la flamme
s'allume des vacances en forme d'hymne à
la nature un retour aux sources
loin de la ville et de sa pollution